львів перетворився на політичну столицю
україни може бути і всією східною
Європи 10 вересня
тут несподівано опинився патрік номер
один без перебільшення скажу це Михайло
саакашвілі та його прихильники прорвали
кордон
ви його особисто зустрічали чи це означає що
ви солідарний або схвалюєте ті методи з
допомогою яких сокаш або повернувся на
якщо говорити просто кашель і я
його знаю ще відколи працював
президентом грузії і ми домовилися що
коли він повернеться до України він заїде
у левів і ми з ним зустрінемося він моїм
розумінні громадянин України тому що
він отримав український паспорт та
громадянство у нього забрали вночі таємно у
то моєму розумінні ну абсурд ось одна з
проблем а україна на напряму пов'язане
з політичним класом цієї країни це
звичайно корупція хоче ці можливо
в Україні впоратися з корупцією
враховуючи величезний політичний вплив
олігархів олігархи контролюють багато
телеканали з огляду на наприклад той факт
що глава МВС арсен аваків
займає досі свою посаду незважаючи
на корупційні скандали, що розгорілися
пов'язані з ним у перших треба
обов'язково прийняти закон та відвезти
можливість антикорупційного суду
тому що ті суди, які сьогодні вони
не зможуть реально карати
корупціонерів те, що ми бачимо сьогодні
це лов риби так у стилі discovery
зловили злочинця луценко показав по
всім телеканалам завтра тихо його
відпускають уже нікому це не кажуть і
друга річ це обов'язково
потрібний новий закон про вибори це обіцяв
порошенка, коли я йшов на вибори
відкриті списку пропорційна система
а зараз просто купують округи олігархи
якщо це не змінити вони просто скупити
всю країну, бо є олігархи, є
менше феодали ви маєте рацію але це не можна
зробити за один день, бо українці
не мають досвіду побудови країни
українці зрозуміло є політичні до
керівництву та політичний лідер країни
це Петро Порошенко, який не зміг
радикальність лист рівень корупції
розумієте він продукт цієї системи і в
нього є велике бажання контролювати
все ось я пам'ятаю розмовляв з одним
президентом нашої сторони не буду
називати його ім'я та розкажіть від ваше
розуміння порошенка дуже просто він
президент
він прем'єр він міністр оборони міністр
закордонних справ містер він усі ви коли
описуєте порошенка ось ця думка це
абсолютно я вам скажу що чому то є
заворожений ти путін знаєте шлях а тут
багатьох лідера он як зразок
але не всі про це говорять така правда
тому що багато хто хоче мати
монопольну владу
але це страшно для країни, бо
тоді країна йде вниз